for the past two years i've had the
opportunity to travel with my friends to
amazing destinations
while we can't travel this year i am
virtually meeting up with them to share
our favorite travel memories and where
we're looking forward to heading next
oh my gosh i missed you guys
my friends and i have experienced
life-changing adventures across the u.s
and europe empowered by my marriott bond
way boundless card
earlier this year we began planning for
travel dare season 3
but as you can expect our travels were
put on hold
if you're watching this video you
probably had to cancel a trip or two
yourself so why not let our adventures
on travel dares
inspire your future trip planning
[Music]
i know my favorite one was it was the
extreme tubing we did in salt lake city
the view going down that hill on that
inner tube
was amazing it was such a rush i was
talking about that weeks after that trip
it was just such a rush and it was so
much fun i have to say it was the
suspension bridge
in france like the feeling of even
getting
up there we were just like oh my god
we're going higher and higher
what's gonna happen and then we get
there and the bridge is like
this wide and we're like we're gonna get
on that
um definitely that was like something i
would never do
on my own but for this show i was like
okay we're doing it and i'm glad i did
no one can ever say anything to me ever
again i am the bravest woman alive and i
don't care
what you say all right so my favorite
dare was definitely the
water slide in austria i don't know why
but there's just something about being
thrown
25 feet in the air like a rag doll that
i just really love
it's like i want to go back and do it
again so bad
maybe i would have to say when uh joe
dared me
to go in the individual submarines in
the bahamas i love the water and we got
to be
so close to marine life and like a very
safe way
for us and the environment and it was
just so nice to
just be in the ocean and and feel like
the water and everything
i have to know i saw the video but from
you guys i want to ask you
what was it like being in the quicksand
i don't know it's kind of hard to
describe
you don't feel it when you're in there
but like once you try to move that's
what it actually like pulls on you
like the way it feels it's almost like
you're glued and
cemented into the ground like until you
start doing the technique of kind of
like wiggling your leg
um it's kind of like a strange feeling
but
once you're free it's like you can move
and wiggle your legs again which is like
the first thing i did
uh the bahamas i had never been to any
sort of tropical island or tropical
destination in my life this was my first
time
and everything about that trip was
amazing uh the second i stepped up the
plane i was just like
wow i mean i love the food i love the
people i loved how everything looked i
love the beach
i love the hotel we stayed at the coral
at atlantis everything about that from
start to finish i was just like
yes i understand why people vacation
here for me
it was definitely naples uh mostly
because you know it's like a coastal
city
there's water everywhere we were taking
like boats to places
and i really love that everything about
naples
was what i want in a vacation spot every
time people ask me what my favorite
place was i say switzerland because it
was like
i've never breathed as fresh of
air as i did there it was so weird i was
like why does everything feel so good
here everything's just so
beautiful natural skies were blue it was
like perfect out of a storybook
[Music]
aside from learning like how popular and
delicious the kachapuri was
i think the fact that there are like 40
variations of it was
kind of mind-blowing and now it's like i
guess we have to go back to georgia and
try
the others oh my god that was so good
for me um when we went to wales and we
went on the pontifta aqueducts it was
really cool because it not only was a
stunning structure
and a world heritage site but it was
something that was built like in the
early 1800s so
the engineering is just incredible
the renaissance ex and provence was
probably the coolest hotel i had ever
seen there was this one room we went to
and it had all this really really cool
local art
and some of it was like interactive i'd
never seen anything like it
[Music]
i'm going to be going to rome italy my
wife has never been to italy and i used
to live there so we are
still planning to go there the first
chance we got so
uh paris is on the list as the next trip
now so going back to paris
and i'm actually really excited about
that because i had a great time in paris
so i'm actually half dominican and i've
never been to the dominican republic
it's always been one of those places
that i
really wanted to go it's like white sand
beaches
crystal clear blue water it's gorgeous
there's so much greenery and i'm gonna
get to meet like a bunch of family that
i've never met before in my entire life
so i feel like something like that would
be like a dream
vacation once i can do it hopefully soon
so the first place i'd love to travel to
when we're able to do so is i want to go
back to
armenia with my family because i'm
reunion and i went there
last year for a short period of time for
work and
it was amazing because i was able to
like meet so many family members i've
never met before and just learn about
the country's history and heritage
i also want to take my mom back to
armenia and have her see it after
so many years of not being there and
just see how the country's changed and
stuff
so i'm trying to save up a lot of points
to make that trip happen for us
i've never traveled abroad until travels
there so this is like my first
experience
you know leaving the country you really
see how big the world
is and how much there is to experience i
just see the world just completely
different now i'm just so grateful
to have had that opportunity thanks to
travel there is i got to travel to parts
of this country that
i probably don't know if i would have
ever gone before especially salt lake
city i was like
whoa this city rules utah is incredible
and you know santa fe new mexico is
another place that
just never was really on my radar the
show really gave me an opportunity to
see parts of this country that i hadn't
seen before and i'm very glad that i did
because now i
really want to explore more of the
united states for me i've kind of
always been a little bit scared of like
the unexpected
of the new but this whole experience has
like
completely changed my mind now it's like
i want more of the new i want more of
the things that i've never done before
never seen before never eaten before and
now i feel like
i'm welcoming the new experiences
instead of being scared of them
i can't wait to travel with you all so
soon
where are we gonna go we should plan it
now that's what we have to start
thinking about where are we going next
on our next adventure
and we hope our past adventures inspire
you to make future trip plans too
so that you're ready to go when we're
able to explore again
you